هذا المبنى الذي نتواجد امامه تقريبا تمت
الانتهاء من اعمال ازاله الركاب بنسبه 90%
لكن يعني مئه بالمئه لا يوجد اي حي حتى
الان تم الانتهاء منه بحسب ما شاهدته يعني
انا صباح الامس صباح يوم الخميس اليوم
اصبحنا يوم الجمعه يوم الخميس جلت في
المنطقه في عده مناطق كل المواقع المدمره
ما زالت فيها فرق انقاذ تتابع العمل حتى
الابنيه التي تصدعت يعني نحن هنا لا نقف
فقط في مبنى في مدمر انما الابنيه المحيطه
جميعا كل هذه الابنيه سيحاول زميلي بسرعه
رصدها زميل المصور كل هذه الابنيه
المجاوره يا ابنيه متصدعه او فيها تشققات
جرى اخلاقها من قبل السلطات التركيه
وحقيقه انا صدمت يوم امس عندما جلنا في
اضنه ان هناك مباني كثيره متصدعه هذا
سيخلق مشكله في ماب في المرحله القادمه
هذه المتصدعه تم اخلائها بالكامل كل هذه
المباني التي تشاهدونها على الشاشه هي
مباني متصنعه عفوا متصدعه وفيها بعض
التشققات وقد اخليت بالكامل من سكانها
وهؤلاء السكان حاليا هم في مراكز لواء
مؤقته هذه المباني الان ستخضع لاعاده
تقييم منها ما هو يحتاج الى عمليات ترميم
ومنها ما هو يحتاج الى هدم بالتالي هناك
مرحله اخرى على ما يبدو انها ستكون طويله
نوعا ما وهي عمليه الترميم وعمليه اعاده
الاعمار المساكن المهدمه السلطات التركيه
والرئيس اردوغان كان يتحدث بان هذه
العمليه لن تستغرق اكثر من سنه لكن حتى
حتى هذه السنه يجب ان يكون هناك اماكن
مؤقته السلطات التركيه تفكر في بدائل لا
يمكن ان تكون المدارس والجامعات هي هذا
هذه الاماكن المؤقته لان استمرار العمليه
التعليميه وعوده الطلاب الى المدارس
والجامعات هو شرط ضروري لاستكمال وعوده
الحياه التدريجيه الى هذه الم المنكوبه
بالتاكيد يعني زيدان نحن لا نتحدث عن يوم
ويومين ولا حتى شهر ولا سنه يعني المساله
والمشاهد توحي بان الامور قد تاخذ منحا
تصاعديا الكارثه ليست فقط كارثه بشريه بل
ستتداعى معها كوارث صحيه نفسيه وحتى
اقتصاديه في تركيا وايضا زيدان نريد ان
نعرف يعني لحظه انتشال فلنفرض احياء او
حتى جثث ما هي الخطه اين هم الاحياء الان
وكيف يتم لم شملهم مثلا مع اقارب لهم
وايضا الناس يعرفونهم
نعم الاحياء بدايه عند انتشال اي شخص على
قيد الحياه مباشره هناك فرق طبيه وسيارات
اسعاف موجوده مباشره تتدخل فرق التدخل
السريع اولا في حال يحتاج الى تدخل عاجل
قبل نقله الى المشفى يقومون بهذا التدخل
ومن ثم يتم نقله الى المشفى في حال لم يكن
بحاجه الى التدخل عاجل في هذا الموقع يتم
نقله بالسياره اسعاف الى المشفى او
المدينه الطبيه هنا في مدينه اضنه يتم
علاجه في حال كانت الحاله حرجه يتم فورا
نقله عبر
الطائره جوا الى انقره او اسطنبول